bearskin lake first nation chief lefty
cameron waterman was busy late last week
pressing ottawa for help that's the
message we want to send out to the
government we want boots on the ground
right here in the community but by
saturday he like half of those in his
community
had been laid low with covid nighttime i
just sweats and
and
the runny nose and
the whole shebang the chief was too ill
tuesday for media interviews but a
community spokesman said on the weekend
they were disappointed that after asking
for as many as 40 military personnel to
help run the community on january the
third it was not until january the ninth
sunday that the federal government
responded and then with only six army
rangers at least three of which live in
the community and are just recovering
themselves from covet what canadians are
seeing in the crisis in bearskin lake
is the systemic
indifference
from this federal government the liberal
government uh towards
the health of indigenous people
meanwhile others who live in their vast
northwestern ontario neighborhood have
pitched in to help we want to say thank
you to all these
neighboring communities that have
stepped up to
help us
that aid included this snowmobile convoy
packed with supplies that made the
three-hour trek last week from big trout
lake first nation while the disease has
been relatively mild to moderate for the
community
the fallout in terms of the workforce
the day-to-day operations that has been
brutal on the community indeed if
there's one small blessing it's that
bearskin lake and many other first
nations communities in the region had a
strong vaccination program in place
definitely the situation would have been
could have been much worse if it weren't
for the high vaccination coverage rates
in the community as for ottawa federal
officials continue to monitor the
situation in bearskin lake and will
adjust to conditions david aiken global
news ottawa